why are there so many screenwriters
opposed to structure are they hurting or
helping themselves with this viewpoint
there are there are a lot of people I
always will be
and some of them got Tom Stoppard
himself no less a writer than tom is
really opposed to education you know
kind of this education that is now
offered in graduate schools for
screenwriting and all that but he can
afford to be you know if you're born a
genius you know okay go for it you can
say anything you want do anything you
write brilliantly and it's fine for them
it's natural but for more for most of us
poor unfortunates down here below the
peak of Olympus yeah we have to work a
little harder at it I think I think it
is a misconception of what there is to
be learned they are that many many
people have always done it a certain way
and they sit and suffer and they think
there's a muse that comes down some
people may be very very intuitive about
this story stuff
and for them fine yeah yeah it can work
but what I find is for the vast majority
of people who want to be writers of
screenplays or novels that's not the
case there are tools tools tools there
are tools one needs to master before you
are going to play a inspirational and
fantastic hour orchestral music for
instance you're going to compose and
play don't you need to learn how to play
the piano well yeah that helps don't you
Lee didn't need to know about music and
the theories of music and Composition
hey it would help you'd save yourself a
lot of time in trouble if you do that
and I believe very much that it's the
same with screenwriting there's so much
there really is and the folks that tend
to think that way and defended okay
that's the way they've always worked I
get that you know that's what you want
to work great go pet that do it but I
believe they are bringing into their own
lives far more emotional suffering than
there needs to be there
they it's there's not the Meuse folks if
there is no news it's up to you to come
up with a decent idea that you can then
pull out the correct tools to start
shaping into something that will work
and bring emotional sustenance and
release for an audience I think you had
a blog post that I just skimmed the
beginning of it and it's just that you
you think you put you know we wake up
the the birds are chirping we feel great
and we're inspired and we are going to
write and we get into like page 27 and
we've hit a roadblock so is this what
we're talking about here sort of like
how to find a way out of that roadblock
because we know that okay if we're at
page 47 we're at this point in this
story are we at the midpoint by the way
which is the interesting yeah yeah 48
ish is 47 ish yeah it's about the
midpoint yes I have always said no plan
no detailed plan no Oscar it's just not
going to happen if you're going to build
a house especially an intricate one as
one as intricate as as a screenplay for
a really good movie you have to have
architectural renderings that take it
down to the tiniest dimension and detail
and piece of equipment that is going to
be used you have to be organized about
it disorganized people as a rule don't
do all that well as writer screenwriters
again this is not everybody there are in
fact geniuses don't you just hate them
out there who can do this stuff just
instinctively without even thinking
about it
but there's a handful of them living on
plan
earth at any given time and of course
they can't see it from our perspective
you know that gee maybe you'd have to
work at it but yes there is a lot of
work and a lot to be known and and isn't
it better if you lay the pieces out you
know you have a puzzle puzzle board
before you and you have all you know the
dark pieces here and the light pieces
here and you began to search and see and
fit together something that is going to
be a whole picture by the time you're
through that is a systematic way of
doing something that is very difficult
to do and I would argue the tools the
tools quantifying change understanding
the 14 character categories knowing that
there are 10 modes of plot coming out of
how many heroes and and what the hero's
relationship is to other characters
there's only ten of those and once you
have an idea pick your tent you know
pick which of the ten that's going to
save you a lot of time and a lot of
agony and I would also throw this out I
would challenge listen I am I am open as
anybody to learn here I diving the
lifelong learner myself if if someone
thinks I'm wrong here or has an instance
square that if they can prove that I am
wrong I'd be very interested to hear it
I really would if you think you've found
the 15th category for instance if you've
taken a look at the 14 and understand
what is contained in the 14 categories
if you can come up with a brand new
character category I would love to be
one of the first to hear about it really
usually and I offer that to the students
all the time what I'm usually when I
hear back when they bring things up
rather enthusiastically bless their
hearts it's usually from a
misunderstanding of the 14 or it's a
misunderstanding
of what I'm saying relative to here
local sequences and things like that but
it's okay it I'm I'm happy about hearing
about ways in which I might be incorrect
with this stuff there is room for growth
you